(upbeat dance music)
♪ It's a human sign ♪
♪ When things go wrong ♪
♪ When the scent of her lingers ♪
♪ And temptation's strong ♪
♪ Cold, cold heart ♪
♪ Hardened by you ♪
♪ Some things lookin' better, baby ♪
♪ Just passin' through ♪
♪ No no no, no no ♪
♪ And I think it's gonna
be a long, long time ♪
♪ 'Til touchdown brings
me 'round again to find ♪
♪ I'm not the man they
think I am at home ♪
♪ Oh no, no, no ♪
♪ And this is what I should have said ♪
♪ Well I thought it, but I kept it hid ♪
♪ Cold cold, heart ♪
♪ Hardened by you ♪
♪ Some things lookin' better, baby ♪
♪ Just passin' through ♪
♪ No no, no, no, no ♪
♪ And I think it's gonna
be a long, long time ♪
♪ 'Til touchdown brings
me 'round again to find ♪
♪ I'm not the man they
think I am at home ♪
♪ Oh no, no, no ♪
♪ No no, no no ♪
(audience cheering)